titanfall releases tomorrow we have the
latest GameSpot news update on the xbox
one's resolution the launch version of
titanfall for Xbox one will run in 792 p
the same sub 1080p resolution that the
games beta featured last month lead
engineer Richard Baker of respawn
entertainment confirmed the resolution
and said the studio is tinkering with
ways to upgrade the game's res
post-launch Baker said we've been
experimenting with making a higher and
lower we're thinking of not using
hardware MSA a multi sampling
anti-aliasing and instead using FXAA
fast approximate anti-aliasing the
target is either 1080p non-native
aliased our 900p with FX AAA we're
trying to optimize we don't want to give
up anything for higher res so far we're
not one hundred percent happy with any
of the options we're still working on it
for day one it's not going to change
we're likely to increase resolution
after we ship acre also mentioned the
studio is still working on optimizing
the game to run consistently at 60
frames per second Chris Reuters reviewed
titanfall for us he gave it a
nine-point-oh so to read that review and
loads more information about respawns
first-person shooter head over to
gamespot com